new details Harry and Megan's chaotic
car chase with the paparazzi they say
could have killed them two of our
offices could have been injured
ET has learned that New York police are
looking at all video evidence to piece
together exactly what happened but
here's what we know you can be the
Visionary of your own life
Megan was in New York with Harry and her
mom accepting The Miz foundation's woman
of vision award lots of love but outside
one heckler
words Harry and Megan claim they quote
were involved in a near catastrophic car
chase at the hands of a ring of Highly
aggressive Paparazzi claiming it lasted
over two hours on New York's busy
streets I would find it hard to believe
that there was a two-hour high-speed
chase
with Chase being chased the whole day at
some point the couple hopped into a cab
the driver speaking out today as we win
the block we got blocked by a garbage
truck and all of a sudden paparazzi's
came and started taking pictures they
were behind us I mean they stayed on top
of us that was pretty much it
the NYPD said numerous photographers
made it challenging but there were no
reported collisions summonses injuries
or arrests we spoke with one of the
photogs involved who claims Harry and
Megan's driver made multiple illegal
moves for more insight we brought in
former New York Detective Bo Dietl they
say at one point they pulled into a
police station for help you'd have the
cops right there this is this is not a
third world this is New York City here's
what I want to know how would you keep
them safe all they had to do is pull
over one gets out goes over to the radio
causes hey these guys are followers the
cops will come out of their car and they
would call you know stop them right
there
for Harry it's just the latest chapter
and what has been a lifelong battle with
the paparazzi I don't think there's many
of us who don't recall how his mom died
I think one of the hardest things to
come to terms with is the fact that
the people that chased her through the
into the tunnel with the same people
that were taking photographs of her
while she was still dying on the back
seat of the car but unfortunately when I
think about my mum the first thing that
comes to mind is always the same one
over and over again
Strouds in the car seat belt across with
my brother in the car as well
and my mother driving being chased there
was no protection
one of the feelings that comes up with
me always is the helplessness
being too young being a guy but too
young to be able to help
a woman in this case your mother
Harry and Megan have faced questions
about their portrayal of the paparazzi
critics called out moments from the
trailer for their Netflix docu-series
first this barrage of cameras meant to
show how intensely they are pursued it's
actually a pick of photographers at the
2011 Harry Potter Premiere it also shows
the chaotic frenzy involving the
paparazzi but again it has nothing to do
with Harry and Megan it's actually
president Trump's former attorney
leaving his New York apartment and this
clip it was a UK model arriving to court
no one knows the full truth we know the
full truth
[Music]